[Music]
tell me about being here and supporting
women we have Alexandra ship we have so
money just incredible talent we're just
dating them all around us now it's you
know I'm a member of Women in Film as
well and it's it's such an important
organization and it's such an important
kind of movement that's happening
especially in young Hollywood you see
women supporting women and you see
people building each other up instead of
tearing each other down and it's so
important to continue that and to be
conscious of that what are we having a
pipeline for you because we know we were
all shocked by the news of Shadowhunters
yeah absolutely so that was a big shock
to all of us and we're all devastated
because you know not only do we love the
show and creating these characters and
the show has been such an amazing ride
but we've become a family and I don't
think any of us are ready to say goodbye
but the fandom has been amazing with all
of the hashtag saved Shadowhunters and
everything and if nothing else we're
gonna shoot a kick-ass two-hour finale
and it's gonna be amazing
and we'll see I've got some irons in the
fire I'm gonna do a little bit of music
because I haven't had time for that in
the last few years and I'm dying to
direct so maybe I'll just direct my
first short soon and kind of figure that
out
[Music]
you